Chinese Communist Party Congress is
meeting in Beijing this week where it's
likely to confirm Xi Jinping for a third
term as leader she's absolute control of
Chinese politics has drawn comparisons
to Matador but his government has seen
protests rare in China against its zero
covert policy China's economy is also
struggling due to pandemic restrictions
and sanctions from the west but despite
the Gathering storming storm clouds Xi
Jinping has shown no signs of changing
his foreign or domestic policies
a member of the European Parliament for
the green party and chair of the
European parliament's China delegation
Mr buddakoffer thank you very much for
being on DW news
um we've already heard from Xi Jinping
uh who's being celebrated or has
celebrated rather himself China's
growing Global influence saying that
its power to shape the world has
significantly increased
is that something that worries you
well it is obviously a fact that China's
leadership is today more self-confident
that they have been in many years
and indeed China's leverage has grown
with different policies like the Belton
Road for instance
but I would not unequivocally
uh sign on to she's description of the
overall situation because China has also
been losing quite a lot on many fronts
um it may not be that much of a concern
to the Chinese Communist leadership that
they are going down the drain as far as
public opinion around Europe is
concerned but also in some countries of
the global Styles notably including in
Africa there are question marks about
the real intention of China's hegemonic
policies that you had not seen a couple
of years ago so it's a mixed picture and
I think effectively she's aggressive
foreign policy is undercutting uh
China's um
progress as a leading world power
what about China's tacit support of
Russia's invasion of Ukraine though its
threats towards Taiwan and and its
attitude towards human rights in Hong
Kong and its treatments uh of the uyghur
minority
uh that's certainly worsened EU China
relations in recent years how should the
EU be reacting to that
well different EU institutions have been
more or less outspoken on all these
issues I would claim that the European
Parliament has been a leader in voicing
adequate criticism
we have raised all the issues in several
resolutions of the European Parliament
that have found uh overwhelming support
only left-wing and right-wing extremists
are dissented from our common position
uh commission if you look carefully is
also enhancing for instance the economic
relationship with Taiwan as is Germany
to cite one member state so there are
changes uh developing and I think
there's more awareness around Europe
today and more cohesion also on that
basis that China is posing threats to
our values our interests and our
Democratic way of life and there's
increasingly a willingness to also um
address that so for instance in the
Human Rights Council of the United
Nations
we lost a vote over having a debate
about the human rights High
Commissioners report on xinjiang but
what has not been commented a lot was
the fact that this was the first time
ever European countries and like-minded
partners even tried to have a vote on
China's human rights record so
increasingly we're standing up for what
we believe
okay let's see what happens then
hopefully uh there is some movement from
Europe side Reinhardt member of the
European Parliament for the green party
and chair of the European parliament's
China delegation thank you very much
have a good day